all these networks that are talking
about football they are fooling
themselves
what do you mean it's going to be a
disaster there is
there is no way football is going to
be able to to go on you're crazy
why not one there's 53-man roster
plus a trainer plus trainer plus coach
they're not going to be in a bubble so
they could their mlb is not in a bubble
though
that's that's not going to last you
don't think they finish the season out
no i don't think they're going to finish
did you look at the marlins right they
had all those cases everyone's like oh
my god let's shut down the season
tomorrow's like yeah but called up some
other people here's the difference
though the difference with baseball
you're not standing next to anybody you
know the center field is standing out
there
doing nothing just like you know it is
true like if
one offense alignment has it well if
patrick mahomes gets it
it's gonna be problems yeah if the
superstars get then you got problems
that's what i'm saying but
it doesn't i disagree i i think what
he's saying is more important
i think if the left tackle gets it and
then everybody on the line is going to
get you know
on both lines on both lines they can't
they're talking about wearing some kind
of mask but they're that is a
full contact sport that if they're not
going to have a bubble
how are they going to do it like it's
going to decimate the season because
the difference between baseball and
football is baseball got a
60 games if the marlins don't play for a
week nobody gives
the [ __ ] by the way if the mothers don't
play at all nobody gives her no
but in football you're talking about
it's a 16 game
uh a season everybody matters every game
matters
what are they going to do they're going
to reschedule like okay so the redskins
can't blow and they can't have been
calling that anymore whatever they're
they're the watchers watching football
football washington by the way the worst
watching football what's the matter well
but well here's the thing they they
they're gonna rename it but they
couldn't because a bunch of fans bought
the rights to all the names they thought
they were gonna go to so it's a legal
battle now
because i know that i think they want to
do the washington uh red tails
which were the world war ii
african-american pilots dope name
dope logo but they couldn't do it did
you hear that there was a group that
wanted to call them the washington skins
and i was like
what might be worse the skins i know i
know people call them anyways yeah man
but it's
clearly an abbreviation like you're
really scared for god's sakes
like calling a team yeah yeah
i i think i know they were leaning
towards the washington
senators which was if the movie with
keanu reeves the
replacements yeah it's like come on man
get creative over there watching but
anyway
my point is i just don't see that though
i don't see football i think it's a
disaster waiting to happen and they
think they can do it because there's so
much money on the line
there's so much money in college
football college football this
how can you have cop this is why college
football is not going to go in my
opinion
i love that you don't think it's good no
no even though they're planning to have
fans and everything
no no it's never going to happen um
because they're not going to hate it
because they're not even going to be at
school and and now
in that cc there's listen it's all hell
the sec is going to school
yes right it's still all hypocrisy
if the college athlete now sees that
they're going hey we want to play
because now they know that it's all
about money
then the college athlete now is going to
be like bingo we want some of that money
bingo yeah and so that's why
it's going to be that's going to be the
legal battle right there and they should
get money
and this puts more you know chips in the
corner be like hold up
now you want to split now you want us to
play but you want to push the season
back
and then make it play the other season 2
on 21 back to back yeah spring and fall
and then
just some money and they've made the
ncaa uh they've
they've exposed the ncaa as frauds oh
they're the biggest
corrupt and they don't even need a [ __ ]
they don't even need them because
there's five
the five major things are like okay
here's what we're gonna do yeah
you guys can do what you want but that's
what we're doing but it's like but have
you seen the the
i think it's the the big 10 big 12
because
their chancellor president came out said
before anybody
because they thought they're the big
dogs with ohio state michigan michigan
state penn state they went
we're not playing we're we're not going
to play their first goal everybody else
is going to follow us and the other
league's win
you know like sec ac no no we're playing
and then those teams like the big boys
ohio state mission were like
no we want to play [ __ ] you know
speak for us yeah so now that they're
proposing that
ohio state penn state uh five or six
teams they're gonna have their own
season without that commission they're
gonna do it themselves can i ask you to
question each other twice
about the ncaa you don't think it's
gonna go down no what i'm saying is like
that's all gonna be like
for what like they're the whole point of
how
why we love it is the rivalries the fact
that there is a season we know what
they're playing for
all that stuff is going to be taken away
they think that we just want to watch
people play football and that's
it i think a lot of people do just want
to watch people play football but i have
a question about the players scenes in
me no
i have a question about the players so
because i had heard college players
and i and i i have no idea if this is
true if a college player
say breaks his leg playing football the
school
covers that or the family has to cover
that the school covers it okay well hold
on if you did it while you were playing
football
the school covers it yeah but say you're
playing football
and you get covered and there's hospital
they cover
i think what i what i read was and what
the pac-12 players were like
we're that's one of the things that
they're fighting for
the pac-12 if you look at that if you
have any that's particular
you look at their demonstrations and
when they're like we want 50
of whatever you bring in and so the
pac-12 commissioner is like
hold on do you realize if we give you 50
that 50 pays for every other sport no
other sport makes money name another
sport
women's sport that make no money so
title nine if there's men there has to
be
women right so if we give you 50 all
these other
sports are gone all those women's sports
all your friends that's gone and i say
that's your problem yeah that's what i
say i say sorry yeah
sorry tennis team you know because the
problem is the way
this is a this is a more of a systematic
problem but you think they should pay
the football players and cut the other
sport no no i'm saying that this is
exposing a problem
how the colleges are run in the first
place even
even where money is allocated where
money comes from
why the money is being spent you know
the the fact that
education is for profit is the problem
in the first place
yes okay so the fact that you're saying
it costs you eighty thousand dollars to
sit in this chair and learn from us
is that's part of the issue so you go
all right you're just not gonna make the
same amount of money that you're making
in college and you know
the money has to be spread out in a
different way or the tuition but also
this is the other thing that
pisses me off and i've been through it
firsthand they go
well we are giving something we're
giving them an education i promise you
at these big schools and i played big
time college football
you are not learning anything but
college football right it takes up
all your [ __ ] time you get the
easiest classes on the schedule so they
just want you to stay eligible
then you get done you're like i learned
nothing when i got my degree the kid
behind me i won't say his name
my first day of school but he was the
first friend i met he i swear to god i
swear on my mother he asked me how do
you spell
chair i thought he was joking because
you were like i don't know
he's behind me how the [ __ ] did you
how the [ __ ] is this happening you have
a degree from music university of
colorado
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just read a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son